foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report at a special time yes you
are not freaking out or having some sort
of medical condition it is 2 p.m Eastern
on July 18 2023 we're a couple hours
late today I was on the Patrick Bet
David podcast uh this morning which is
up in Fort Lauderdale so had a bit of a
drive and a hike to get up there was
there for a couple hours uh if you did
not see it we had a great conversation
about Trump to Santa's vivec culture the
stuff you can check that out on
Patrick's YouTube channel and we've got
a big show for you today as always post
game show over at
reubenreport.locals.com and I think if
I'm not mistaken that today is a Reuben
report first I am doing the Dave Rubin
travel outfit on the show that's right
I'm wearing a t-shirt not the open
collar that you've come to expect and
love and often send me very uh
unpleasant messages about because you'd
like to do things to me me that you
can't do I don't know you you don't know
me but people do love that but today
this is Dave Rubin when I go to the
airport this is more of my travel look
there you go uh so that is happening and
speaking of things that are happening
like as we speak uh I guess just in the
last two hours or so uh some more legal
nonsense mumbo-jumbo has happened
related to President Trump we'll cover
more of it uh tomorrow because we
already had the show basically set for
today but I want to cover it real quick
in case you haven't heard this is from
the daily wire Trump expects to be
arrested indicted by special counsel
Jack Smith in 2020 election case so
again I don't want to cover too much
about it right now because I want to oh
do we have some more oh well we do have
some more uh former president Donald
Trump I thought we were just doing a
headline let's do it let's do the whole
thing as long as we're here doing a show
former president Donald Trump uh said
Tuesday he has been informed by special
counsel Jack Smith that he is a criminal
Target of a Washington DC grand jury
investigating his alleged efforts to
overturn the 2020 election Trump
announced on Truth social that he said
he got a Target letter Sunday night in
which Smith's office offered him the
opportunity to appear before the grand
jury this week the development indicates
another indictment could be on the way
although it does not say What charges
Trump would face he is under indictment
in Manhattan in connection with an
alleged hush money payments to Stormy
Daniels and in Florida where Smith's
office accused him of mishandling
sensitive documents so obviously this is
not going anywhere we will continue to
cover it do want to mention that the
Florida case has nothing to do with the
state of Florida it is a federal case I
would also say broadly on all of this we
need to understand more so what the
specific charges are if the charges are
that he incited a riot I mean they are
going to have a hell of a time uh
getting him on that because he
repeatedly said you can go and you can
protest but do it peacefully
Etc et cetera including tweets that he
sent out that were subsequently taken
down and a bunch more I would also say
broadly this is nothing but a Witch Hunt
it continues to be a Witch Hunt and for
these people that are due in The Witch
Hunt it seems fairly obvious to me you
guys either want Trump to stay in the
news so that he gets the nomination
because you think he's easier to beat
than say one of the other guys uh or
you're actually trying to jail him in
which case uh you're not good people
either way you are not good people and
uh yeah we shall see where this goes I'm
being told on the Fly there is a Tuesday
question for me you guys have a question
I don't know that I have not heard this
question you're going to tell me what
you're going to ask me a question right
now and I'm gonna have to answer it on
the Fly go ahead
what city is Patrick Bet David from well
he's from Iran right he's Persian
originally I think he's from Iran so
what city in Iran
um would it be
um
I don't know give me a city uh give me a
city in Iran Tehran about Tehran Tehran
would be my guess I mean that's the main
yeah he's from here
ah you see why you watch this show it's
all there people the question is whether
you can get to it he is from Tehran Iran
I don't know that I could have come up
with three other cities in Iran so that
was
all right uh the theme of our show today
is Hollywood crumbling right now and how
that's connected not just to the woke
thing but the sort of broader uh
collapse of all of our institutions as
you know Hollywood Riders are going
through a strike that now many actors
are jumping on board uh this is also
connected to the sports world and
perhaps it is good as these things
crumble because we need some new things
and I think ladies and gentlemen that
we've got a solution to combating the
lunacy we'll get to that at the end let
me talk to you about Patriot Supply and
then we'll get to it uh why are so many
people buying emergency food right now
well as tensions continue to escalate
our fragile food supply chain could
break down again one shocking headline
spreads Panic like wildfire and grocery
stores grocery stores are empty within
hours this means you really need a
proper supply of emergency food on hand
before disaster strikes you'll breathe
easier knowing you can feed your family
in crisis go to prepare with reuben.com
for your one week emergency food supply
my patreon Supply is the nation's
largest preparedness company with
millions of happy worry-free customers
it comes in a Nifty ammo can that's
loaded with delicious foods there's no
need to skimp on meals because they
offer 2 000 calories per day don't skip
the special 30 savings available this
week only on the one week emergency food
supply go to prepare with reuben.com
let's prepare with reuben.com and now
back to me okay so let's dive right back
into it I mentioned last week because we
covered a story related to former NBA
star now quite excellent sports
broadcaster Charles Barkley that I like
Charles Barkley a lot I actually like
Charles Barkley more as a broadcaster
than I like them as a player he didn't
play a lot of Defense I liked some teams
that were going against him uh
particularly the Rockets when they were
going against the Suns in 95 but Charles
has become an excellent broadcaster he's
funny as hell he is outspoken for the
most part I really like this guy but he
seems to be a little confused related to
some of the woke topics the the thing we
hit him on last week was that after the
affirmative action decision was made by
the Supreme Court Barkley announced that
he was going to to donate five million
dollars after his death so not right now
but after his death five billion dollars
for black kids to get scholarships to
Auburn and it's like I don't know why
you're still focusing on race and also
Charles hopefully you have another 50
years on this planet if we're still
focused on this 50 years from now
where you just want black kids to get
into school it's like this is a problem
also five million dollars 50 years from
now is probably going to get one kid
into college because that's how
expensive college will be anyway so you
kind of missed the mark on that but he's
missed the mark on something else and I
think it's worth noting because he is
sort of uh I would say culturally
relevant this is a headline from the New
York Post Charles Barkley defends Bud
Light slams Dylan Mulvaney critics as
rednecks and the former NBA
star turned television commentator was
seen in a video clip that went viral on
social media chastising those boycotting
Bud Light we've got a quote from the New
York Post and then we've got some video
for you all you rednecks or who
don't want to drink Bud Light F y'all
the out spoken television commentator
told a cheering crowd at a bar in Lake
Tahoe California where he was playing in
a celebrity golf tournament over the
weekend uh let's take a look at that
video and then we shall dissect
hey
[Applause]
bless you
if your transgender miss you
and if you have a problem with that
[Applause]
Brave powerful and brave now first off I
don't have a problem with gay people I
have noted once or twice before my
husband's gay okay that's one thing I
don't have a problem with trans people
in that if you are an adult and wish to
dress however you want live however you
want uh it's not my thing I don't think
you should be encroaching on children
and all of those things but you can live
how you wish to live and if you treat me
with respect I'll treat you with respect
the problem is that respect is a two-way
street that seems to be lost not a whole
bunch of people the issue when he says
all right if you're gay God bless you
okay that's fine if you're trans God
bless you and he says if you have a
problem with that Fu now that that's the
problem because what he's confused by
and this is what I think a lot of the
walksters and even the people who cite
who sort of potentially at some level
understand what's really going on here
what they miss is that it's not that
people necessarily have a problem with
trans people people didn't have a
problem with trans people
until all of this nonsense related to
kids and drag queen Story Hour and all
of the books that are in schools and
Disney pushing this stuff and everything
else so for him to flippantly dismiss it
like if you're gay God bless you and
you're trans God bless you and if you
don't agree F you like you're not
addressing what the real issue is it's
it's just such like a simplistic
nonsensical version of what really is
happening there and I would hope that
Charles Barkley uh that if he had a
young child I think he has a couple kids
if I'm not mistaken if he had a young
child and his young son suddenly thought
he was a girl I hope that Charles would
fight the machine as it tried to
chemically castrate his son or change
the child's pronouns or put the child on
hormones and all of the stuff and he
probably would he probably would so it's
not this is one of the things the left
does really well it's like you either
love everybody or you're an evil mfer
and we have to stop playing that game
but that game whether it comes to uh
gender and sexual in this nonsense or uh
race it does not seem to want to let go
so I want to read you this tweet by this
is a Washington Post reporter a
Washington Post journalist by the name
of Emily Yar she writes as Luke Combs
hit cover of Tracy Chapman's fast car
dominates the country charts it's
bringing up some complicated emotions in
fans and singers who know that Chapman
as a queer black woman would have an
almost zero chance at that achievement
herself now you might remember the song
Fast Car by Tracy Chapman because it was
a massive hit when it came out 30 some
odd years ago and Community notes the
fact-checking apparatus of Twitter made
note of that Fast Car by Tracy Chapman
was nominated for three Grammy Awards
including record of the year and song of
the year she won for best female pop
vocal performance and Best New Artist of
oh and she has seven other nominations
for Grammy Awards and two other wins so
the way that the Washington Post frames
this is because that this white guy
because what they're saying is he's a
white guy he's you know country singer
he must somehow also be a white
supremacist some of that nonsense he's
going to make a whole bunch of money and
win a whole bunch of awards on this song
uh this Tracy Chapman song and she could
oh but she did win a whole bunch of
awards and she became super rich on it
and then here's the best part not only
did she get do they get fact checked
Washington Post and that ridiculous
quote-unquote journalist but even Tracy
Chapman herself is speaking out against
this nonsense here uh is a quote that
she gave to people Chapman 59 spoke
about the cover in an exclusive
statement to billboard writing I never
expected to find myself on the country
charts but I'm honored to be there
praising the new version by Combs 33 she
continued to the outlet I'm happy for
Luke and his success and great full that
new fans have found and embraced fast
car so do you see what the machine does
with absolutely everything you had I
didn't know she was queer but okay
you've got a queer black woman who is a
multiple Grammy winner She's Got To Be A
Millionaire making tons of money still
on residuals and all of that stuff a
young country singer and this guy is
he's a major star right now he comes in
does a cover of it she gets residuals on
that stuff it's not like he's just
jacking the song and that's it
everybody's making money everybody gets
to hear more of her songs Washington
Post the machine the corporate press
machine decides to make it about race
and racism and opening up conversations
about queer
and it's all B
it's all Bs much like remember the story
we covered last week about Jonah Hill
who sent out very tepid uh tweet uh
texts to his girlfriend saying hey you
know I'd prefer you not put out nude
pictures and these are the things that I
need if you want to be in a relationship
with me and then all of the mainstream
media said he was a misogynist and he
hates women and
this is what they do with everything and
they do not stop right so Hollywood
which is in complete free fall right now
because of the writer strike did you
even know uh you person watching this
right now on the other side of that
screen do you even know that the late
night shows are not even on right now
because there are no writers because the
writers are on strike does anyone watch
those shows is there anyone that's out
there like where is Colbert I can't fall
asleep I I just can't imagine but anyway
Hollywood's on strike it's a big issue
but the wokeness in Hollywood is not
going anywhere and what is the epicenter
of the woke well of course it is Disney
Disney which is crumbling their profits
their market share the whole thing and
new CEO Bob tiger who is also old CEO
because he was the CEO years ago then
that guy another Bob Bob chapic took in
bobc put the thing put the woke thing on
steroids right Eiger comes in to kind of
clean it up uh here he is talking about
DeSantis and trying to tell people that
Disney's not actually woken they're not
sexualizing kids you see if you believe
him what about DeSantis who's going to
be on the husting so to speak for the
next year and he's going he's made this
a part of his campaign attacking Disney
saying it's a woke Corporation we've put
the company on a pedal slope but they've
really embraced the idea of getting
these sexualized content in the program
line that I'm not willing to cross I
mean that's what he said I quoted
DeSantis there how do you respond to
that
well so far what we've said publicly is
that we are
concerned that he has decided to
retaliate against the company for a
position The company took on pending
legislation in that state and frankly
the company was within its right even
though I'm not sure it was handled very
well it was within its right to speak up
on an issue
constitutionally protected right of free
speech and to retaliate against the
company in a way that would be harmful
to the business the notion that Disney
is in any way sexualizing children quite
frankly is is preposterous and
inaccurate
the notion that Disney is sexualizing
children is quite frankly preposterous
Connor are you ready
roll the tape the notion that Disney is
in any way sexualizing children quite
frankly is is preposterous and
inaccurate hello and welcome to the
Disney plus this is me Pride Celebration
spectacular text to me this morning you
know gen Z is 30 to 40 percent queer
than the other Generations mom so Disney
better get with it our leadership over
there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda they've been really
open to exploring queer stories I'm on
the production side and so kind of the
only way to have these like canonical
trans characters canonical asexual
characters canonical bisexual characters
is to give them stories where they can
like be their whole selves I identify as
like a biromantic asexual I want to like
add the pop the the pockets of the lgbtq
community That You Don't See I was like
I want to get like gay Advanced and so
we no longer say ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls it's hello everyone or
Hello friends we were targeting gen Z
and Millennials we were targeting a
younger
um all this content's going for to kids
who don't know any of this and even if
they're in a household like Keith uh
that have uh supportive parents they're
still getting all of this information
from media of what is normal
oh Bob Iger you're not going to be a fan
of mine
um can any of you in this room tell me
what a canonical asexual character might
be is there a child that's uh say four
or five years old wants Mommy and Daddy
and I could this could happen to me in a
couple years when the kids want to go to
the movie theater what if one of the
boys looks up Daddy I want to see a
canonical asexual character
yeah
what what I just made that kid a little
Asian the kid became a little Asian
there a little robotic Daddy I want to
see a canonical asexual baby
how are these people talking about
anyway this these people right put those
people aside for a second if that's not
bad enough the canonical asexual
characters
five second one Star Wars
um the other thing that Disney has
destroyed is they've absolutely
destroyed Star Wars everyone knows
they've destroyed Star Wars and they've
really now started to make a mess of
Marvel which when they took over they
did a bunch of good things with but now
Marvel's starting to struggle too here's
Iger on how they are actually stepping
away from some of those properties
because you know they bought everybody's
dreams right Disney at all of the Disney
dreams all of the Disney stories they've
had over decades they bought Marvel they
bought Star Wars and do you think ladies
and gentlemen that maybe one giant
corporate conglomerate shouldn't own all
of our dreams perhaps maybe listen to
Tiger himself
Marvel and Star Wars too much I mean you
almost indicated kind of it's It's been
a little much do you pull back in a way
yes you do yeah
yeah you pull back not just the focus
but it's also part of our Cost
Containment initiative
you know spending less making spending
Less on what we make and making less
Eddie hey
okay the joking aside for just a second
if I could possibly do this with a
straight face Star Wars was demolished
which would like it captured Generations
it captured the imagination of
generations I certainly know he captured
my uh imagination and and literally
millions and millions of other people
but then they decided instead of writing
great stories with great characters they
decided these things had to be woke they
were afraid to take risks when George
Lucas created the original Star Wars he
was fighting the studios right there's
the very famous story of him fighting
the studios over budget so he eventually
decides to take the money for the
licensing rights for the toys which no
one thought kids were going to play with
Little Star Wars toys he ends up making
billions of dollars on that uh I tweeted
when I saw this video I I tweeted that
out and I said something to the effect
of how George Lucas should now buy back
Star Wars from Disney and then
say you know what just announced it was
all nonsense what they've done with it
and we're going to restart this whole
thing I know he's kind of bitter about
what happened and the fans turned on him
and he hasn't been treated fairly uh by
by so many people after creating
something that was loved and is loved by
so many so many people but he could just
hand it to somebody else and by the way
he's worth about
4.2 billion dollars can you see how much
money did George Lucas sell Star Wars
for I wanted the number on that last I
saw he's worth about 4.2 billion now he
could probably buy Star Wars back on the
cheap and then save it what a cool story
with that would be how much
how much he sold it for four and he's
worth 4.2 still he made he made 2.2
billion dollars since then it's still
pretty good well he probably had some
cash but you get the point anyway they
have demolished classic films they've
demolished franchises and the point is
they're not focusing on them enough they
are focusing on something else as my
friend Peter bagozian often says once a
company or an institution
entertainment government whatever it is
one it's once it allows wokeness in its
eye is no longer on the ball right what
is the what is the goal of Disney the
film portion of Disney there's the parks
portion the parks portion is to create
the greatest adventure for a day for a
family to go and spend a hundred dollars
on uh popcorn and whatever else but the
day is so that the hopefully is the
family spends a certain amount of money
the company makes money the family walks
away saying boy that was worth doing it
was fun our kids had a great time we're
going to come back we're going to tell
our friends about it that's what the
parks do the movies are supposed to
capture your imagination so that you
will go back and see more of the company
makes money and you feel entertained and
everything else but once you let woken
you no longer are focused on the mission
right you are focused on a whole bunch
of other things we better not have a
canonical Jedi and of asexual
so they're always focused on the wrong
things once they get focused on the
wrong things they destroy the things
which is exactly why Eiger is pulling
back from Star Wars and Marvel right now
let's not pretend it's for any other
reason uh and one of the other things
that that leads to is an entire industry
Hollywood which is now beginning to
crumble we have a headline from CBS
Hollywood drama actors join writers in
Striking against producers and now I
want to show you actually this little
text there but we can we can jump past
that I want to show you this interesting
uh moment on a podcast that I saw a
comedian Theo Von and actor Adam DeVine
who you've seen in a whole bunch of
things uh they were talking about how
just as I just said that once you allow
wokeness into something and in their uh
what they're discussing is comedy and
movies once you allow it in it will
destroy the whole freaking thing take a
look they there used to be something
like every Studio would put out several
comedies every every year and there was
like 45 or 46 comedies in the theaters
every year so about every week or every
other week or so there's a new comedy in
the theaters and uh and then now last
year there was like six or seven
crazy crazy and people need and the
crazy thing is is this feels like people
need comedy more than ever yeah I feel
like they want it I feel yeah so that's
what this movie was it was like and
there's no like hidden message I feel
like nowadays
people like you get to the end of what
you think is a comedy and you're like is
that about global warming yeah yeah
you're like is this is just like some
deep hidden message that I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to recycle more or like you
know yeah there has to be something else
right oh the Moon is trans is that what
yeah is that the surprising yeah yeah
okay I guess we do have to think about
that don't we
yeah I agree there's there's a lot of
what was that was a great and that's
what your David Spade and your movie is
about yeah trans Moon yeah yeah
these are just the people to to spread
that message oh it's about
Transportation it's about a lot of
vehicles admitting who they really are
the cars wanting to be motorcycles
motorcycles wishing they were scooters
yeah it's just it's where things are you
guys get it they push out all of this
nonsense trans this Transat there were
five Transformer movies more than meets
the eye you see what I did there not the
funniest thing I've ever said kinda you
could have put in a sound effect of it
do we have a warrant why we should have
one guys no okay I'll take that
um
now the issue they're making they're
actually making a good point though if
you think about what entertainment
really is so think whatever you think
for you guys what what is your favorite
comedy movie of all time mine is Naked
Gun without question Naked Gun which was
the next version of it was to me it was
airplane on steroids I was 13 years old
when I saw it I thought it was the
funniest freaking thing in the history
of the world I remember seeing it in the
movie theater a fat man who was sitting
in front of me in the aisle seat
actually fell out of his chair into the
aisle from laughing so hard but whatever
your favorite movie is whether it was
Naked Gun airplane Best in Show whatever
your whatever you love like they weren't
trying to teach you anything they were
trying to make you freaking laugh
Seinfeld's probably the best example of
that as a sitcom it was never trying to
teach you anything it was just going for
the laugh we can all think back to the
sitcoms that every now and again like
every eighth episode would suddenly be
oh my God that guy did crack and what's
gonna what we have to teach a lesson now
like these corny things but that's not
what this should be about now so you
might go well why is it why is it that
Hollywood went so woke why is it that
this stuff keeps getting pushed on us
there's a very specific reason it it's
coming from the top down and one of the
ways that the banks and the corporations
and the Machine push all of this woke
nonsense is through ESG we've talked
about ESG an awful lot before it's
called environmental social and
corporate governance this is basically
the way the banks and the banks and the
government so this is actual fascism
Force corporations to have diversity in
their companies and have all these
ridiculous departments and put out
products that are going to be more
environmentally friendly which is a
giant grift and all of that stuff so now
you're going to watch something that is
going to well it's not gonna blow your
mind because you're you're a wise viewer
of the Reuben report but there was a
hearing a congressional hearing
yesterday in DC about ESG
and here is
communist socialist I'm not even going
to say a couple of the other words I
think of this woman from Michigan
Rashida Talib asking some questions
about ESG and wait to the end really
listen to what she says here
they fractured homes are rising costs
you're saying it's ESG I'm saying it's a
contributor and it is buying it's a
contributor it is when did ESG come up
in the manufactured homes industry when
ESG
when did it come about when did they
start talking about 2019 18. we're
facing these doe when did they start
talking about ESG in your industry
no I really mean it you guys because
understand this this is the bizarre
thing I've never even heard of ESG until
now
that was a hearing on ESG how many times
have I mentioned ESG on the show Glenn
Beck has written several books about it
Florida as a state has banned ESG
um ESG as I just explained this is how
they're forcing all of this stuff and
this communist this awful LARPing
actress pretending to be a a a
congresswoman she did not even know what
ESG was and she had the balls
pardon my French to say that at the
hearing about esj
we've played you video of BlackRock CEO
Larry Fink pushing for ESG back in 2017.
remember this video here's how we can
force people to do the societal change
that we want it is just so extraordinary
and it tells you that there is no bottom
to the pit that now is the modern
Democrat Party and their connections to
all of this but it even goes further
there was another hearing about climate
change you know these are people in
government these are very serious people
they bring in people they ask them
questions nothing ever changes but they
sit there and they talk
and here's a tree man what's his he's in
he's an ant but I his name is
Treebeard you know him as John Kerry I
call him Treebeard from The Lord of the
Rings movies over there uh here is John
Kerry our former climates are under
Barack Obama who's now still flying all
over the country and all over the world
in his private jet here he is explaining
a bit about climate change to the people
of congress you ask the question what's
it going to look like I
that depends on what we decide to do
it's very obvious that there are huge
threats here literally food production
for an entire continent could implode
water is already diminishing last year
the Rhine River was down to inches they
had to stop navigation on the river
because of that you're seeing glaciers
that are now absolutely predictable as
to when they will be completely gone
and and at the rate the ice is melding
in the north and south of our Antarctic
Antarctica
there are dire predictions now about how
that's moved forward by about 30 years
at the pace of which the the it is
Vanishing uh and parts of the Earth are
warming much faster than other parts of
the Earth the Arctic for instance is
warming four times faster than the rest
of the earth other places are we're
hitting heat levels in places that have
never been lived by human beings so on a
regular basis
oh no heat levels in places that humans
have never lived I guess they're going
to continue not to live there look
everything he said there is nonsense
this jackass flies his private jet all
over the world they live in a way that
they would never allow you to live you
have nothing to worry about and don't
worry they're not worried about it
either which is why Barack Obama lives
on a 30-acre estate on the water in
Martha's Vineyard don't worry no illegal
immigrants over there but now here's the
kicker of this freaking thing they asked
John Kerry about him flying his own
private jet around the world to talk
about climate change and you will just
love this freaking answer
so uh I just don't agree with your facts
which began with the presentation of one
of the most outrageously persistent lies
that I hear which is this private jet we
don't own a private jet I don't own a
private jet I personally have never
owned a private jet and obviously it's
pretty stupid to talk about coming in a
private jet from the state department up
here
just honestly if that's where you want
to go go there
a few moments later you uh just
testified under oath that you never
owned a private jet Mr chairman I'd like
to enter into the record uh article here
from February 15th of 2000 2023 the John
Kerry family private jet was sold
shortly after accusations of climate
hypocrisy Mr secretary you stand by that
testimony that you've never owned or I
personally family
personally yes my wife owned a plan
[Music]
oh oh I completely forgot my wife on the
plane yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah also
he's a lizard person do you notice how
when he talks to the tongue
it keeps popping out of it
I never rode a plane oh my white bone
I can't take these people I cannot take
it I cannot take it all right let's
shift to sanity let's shift into sanity
uh because related to all of this as you
know DeSantis has been really the main
guy standing up to this nonsense and
people appreciate it and I think the
more that he gets out there and shares
that message with the average person as
much as the media is going to go after
him and Trump and whatever I think more
and more people are going to see it uh
here he is in Tennessee yesterday
calling out the Republicans who were
siding with Disney because as you know
Mike Pence went after him oh it was a
little bit much to go after Disney we
don't like to use the government to do
that Chris Christie Nikki Haley a whole
bunch of them went after DeSantis were
doing it but the average person sees
that what DeSantis did was right and
they appreciate it I have most
of me for siding with the children
versus Disney and that's a vision of the
Republican party when you're siding with
woke corporations over your own
constituency that is not going to win
elections and it's not the morally right
thing to do we have to draw a line on
the sand when it comes to our children
we oppose the sexualization of minors
and we will battle anybody who seeks to
Rob them of their innocence even the
biggest baddest Corporation of them all
we will stand for what's right
you can't do that you've got no business
being elected dog catcher as a
Republican
yeah yeah see I didn't have to I don't
have to make any crazy comments talk
about canonical asexuality or anything
yeah it's just simple and you know it
and you get it and the people appreciate
it okay fine I want to show you one more
clip I just had this because something
really great happened yesterday you know
when I when I did the show yesterday and
by the way we went through some comments
yesterday
thank you for the uh the kind words on
yesterday's show I do I think we really
kind of nailed it and tried to frame
things in a little bit of a I don't know
more clear way I suppose politically
because it was our first sort of pure
political show in a while uh but the two
questions that I posed at the top of the
show yesterday were when you're deciding
who to vote for I think you have two
things that you have to think about you
have to think number one do I roughly
agree with this guy politically like
does he do I basically agree with what
his political positions are right so you
that's for you to decide and you might
say Trump and someone might say DeSantis
or Nikki or whoever it might be you
might say RFK doesn't matter and then
the second question is do can this
person accomplish these things do you
believe that they have a track record
and the ability to go ahead and
accomplish the things that are the
issues in question number one obviously
I think that's DeSantis now what's
interesting that's going on right now is
there is a war there is an absolute War
brewing in the in the Republican party
and that war is do we go and do the
Trump thing again or do we do the the
new blood the Santa thing that that
really is what it all boys now dude
there's a lot of other characters and
everyone's playing their role and all
that but there was a really interesting
moment yesterday with uh DeSantis doing
a q a uh with a nice woman who asked him
a question in a really beautiful way and
I think I think this is this captures a
lot of what probably all of you are
going through take a look
I was invited to come today to listen to
you by this gentleman representative
Moss
I'm a very hardcore Trump supporter
but I know
he made me stop and think a minute
because my love for president Trump
comes from all the despair all the
things that he's been through has served
as our president of the United States
and he did a good job
but all the things I'm thinking more
with my heart and my sorrow and my love
for him and for this country but now I
have this is the most important vote
that we're going to have and I have to
think more with my mind and what's best
for this country and you did an
excellent job and I certainly appreciate
God bless you thank you
[Music]
and I appreciate that
and um you know I agree with you I
appreciate what president Trump did uh
how they treated him with things like
Russia collusion was a disgrace and um
and he was treated wrong uh he was
treated in ways that were
unconstitutional uh but here's the thing
the question for us now is what are we
going to do about it and we need to end
the weaponization of government I will
get that done it's not about me it's
about you it's about me standing up for
you and standing up for this
Constitution and restoring this country
to what the founding fathers Envision
and and we will we will get it done we
will be focused we will be disciplined
and we will make it happen okay now
watch this ladies and gentlemen what you
just saw right there was a a voter a
citizen of the United States
respectfully and honestly saying exactly
what she believes she freaking loved
Trump trump was treated horribly now she
believes there's a new way to go then
you saw the candidate say he appreciates
what Trump's done he believes that
there's a new way to go and it's done
respectfully and all of those things now
I want to throw back to something we
showed you at the top of the show which
was not done respectfully and then I
think I'll show you the way out so
here's Barkley again earlier
all right guys
[Applause]
bless you
if you're transgender miss you
and if you have a problem with that
[Applause]
so we all have a moment right we can
either tell a huge swath of people to f
off for whatever reason we can all
figure out a reason to tell a whole
bunch of people to f off I often think
about it and sometimes I do it on this
show or we can do with that woman and
DeSantis did right there which is
appreciate good people for their moment
and then perhaps and then this is up to
you guys decide whether it has to be
that person going forward or is there
someone else or what is the difference
between voting with your heart and
voting with your brain or can you
combine those two things or meet in the
middle or whatever it is and the other
way we can defeat this thing not only by
being a little bit better and not
telling everybody to f off is do some of
this fight a little of this with
canonical asex no with humor and that's
exactly what Roseanne did yesterday on
Piers Morgan's show what is a woman
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breaths hang down to her stomach and who
has uh a prolapsed uterus from giving
birth to five ungrateful little bastards
who have never had to work for a thing
in their goddamn life that's what a
woman is
I'd like to give a special shout out to
uh Jake who's Roseanne's son who I used
to do some work with uh who's a good
dude Jake how are you I know you worked
occasionally every now and again and I
want to finish Today's Show with the
other way you can beat him with humor
well you can beat him with The Head and
the Heart right you can beat him with
humor and you can just also beat him
with free speech and with truth and
that's getting tougher because they're
coming for all of it but we can keep
trying allow Ice Cube to take is that
his real name Ice Cube what's your
baby's name ice well here's Ice Cube
what's the answer to this because I
think it's crazy that in a democracy
like the United States like the United
Kingdom the people are too frightened to
speak their mind to say what they think
what do we do about this I think you say
what you want to say
and to hell with the consequences you
got to be willing to fight for your
rights and fight for what you believe in
and if you're a person who believes in
freedom of speech you have to fight
and say what you feel and let chips fall
where they may and uh stand on that and
you know it may not be an easy road but
um I think you feel better about
yourself when you say what needs to be
said at the time it needs to be said and
not afterwards where you go home and
think I should have said this
when that guy was there or when I was
there I should have said that and I
didn't that wants you more
it's Cube I can't argue with that I have
no doubt I have political disagreements
and probably a whole bunch more with Ice
Cube but if you say what you think in
that moment that you're supposed to say
you will probably doesn't mean you're
not going to get punched in the mouth
every now and again you might but it
might just be better than the silent
acquiescence that allows a lot of the
bad characters to gain strength on that
note that is our show for today I would
say this might have been the most
economical asexual show we've ever done
my full interview with RFK Jr
is up on the computer machine you can
find it I know you can we've got a post
game show for you in about 36 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com and we leave you
with noted alt-right leader
Mr Rogers
boys are boys from the beginning if you
were born a boy you stay a boy girls are
girls right from the start if you were
born a girl you stay a girl and grow up
to be a lady
everybody's fancy
Everybody's Fine your body's fancy and
so is my only girls can be the mummies
only boys can be the daddies yes sir
everybody's fancy everybody's fine
thank you
[Music]